[Applause]
braves have now taken the field led by
kyle muller it seems like every time he
has started a game for the braves every
pitch he throws carries such great he is
averaging 1.3 runs of support per game
that he has pitched even for a veteran
guy that is not much of a margin for
error runners at first and third for the
reds here in the top of the first inning
tyler stevenson from kennesaw high
school north of town
on the ground riley got the hop he
wanted perfect throw and mueller works
around a leadoff double cincinnati
strands two in the top of the first
inning vladimir gutierrez here he is a
rookie seven and three respectable
earned run average had a couple of games
where he gave up big numbers but those
will blow that earned run average up
gave up six against the padres in four
innings six against some mets one night
those are the kind that affect your era
but really not the win loss record now
he goes to work against ozzy albee's
stevenson shows the ball all these done
on strikes he'll change his speeds right
in the middle fastball change up change
up freeman with just one hit in this
series he's one for eight
freeman mariah
[Applause]
i'm not sure how cleanly he saw that on
contact but he made up the ground and
made the play
how many times have we seen aquino make
plays like this excellent outfield i'm
not sure what the metrics say about him
but he goes back and catches ball that
look like they're going to go over his
head the last second reaches up and
there's his glove two walks in the
inning brings up dansby swanson
dansby a little pop into right aquino
late break coming on late he can't get
there ball drops a run is in one nothing
in lead on a blue pit
he's set a chip late break
he froze for about a second or two
and that's just enough on this blooper
to get it in and
talk two things put the ball in play
this is exactly what he did look ball
off the plate
last night dansby hit one just like that
for sac fly tonight you get rewarded
with a bloop single and look two walks
they kill two singles and a walk and
it's winker with the bases loaded
winker
rips it to right field and gone
a grand slam from jesse winker
reds four
braves one
winker was so disappointed when he
popped up his first time up he was not
gonna miss this slider mueller hangs it
right there in the hot spot and a line
drive was it high enough was really the
only question gives the resident just a
little bit of breathing
joey bottom to the plate to begin this
top of the third
bottle well hit to right field that's
off the wall
vodka vatomania
alive and well
he is on again
his second clean reach in as many played
appearances today
aquino walks brian schnitker out of the
braves dugout he has seen enough we will
see josh tomlin
suarez
hammered
skips into the stands stevenson scores
aquino will have to hold at third base
hey eugenio suarez
rips a double 5-1 reds well the 2-0
count eugenio's thinking i'm going to
get a pitch right here this guy doesn't
walk anybody he does up and out over the
plate suarez stays right behind that
baseball and would have scored one more
run had it not bounded into the stands
tyler naquin a single a run scored
lakewood turns on it to right field gone
a three-run homer from tyler naked
and the reds are rolling on this getaway
day it is eight to one in the third
inning
seems like all the frustration from the
previous three days on this road trip
starting with cleveland
and then the first two and especially
last night's ball game the extra ending
loss
all come out at one time right here
that's naquin's 14th home run tying his
career high that he said in his rookie
year 2016. so here's jonathan india and
now he'll try to keep the reds third
alive now the braves right he kicks
turns it loose fly ball high in the air
deep left field turning as duvall you
catch that baby goodbye
third home run of the ball game for the
reds
a solo shot for jonathan india that
gives him 14 on the year
and he's made it a 9
1 reds lead five runs here in the third
for the red leg
india is having a pretty good afternoon
evening whatever you want to call it
double walk homer well i think even with
the young legs
of farmer in india you still have to
have a day off every now and then
and the day off yesterday from jonathan
india and he has come back quite a bit
spry adam duvall standing in nobody on
one man out
struck him out well he is eating up the
right-handers with that slider even if
you're committed to hit it you've got to
hold back on a little because this
fastball has some pop
peterson bounced to first
his first time up
india
then he can take his time one two three
inning for vladimir gutierrez red to
lead nine to one as this game moves to
the fifth in atlanta two on but two out
five-time all-star mvp a year ago
freddie freeman
it is spot
farmers sliding stop
tumbling down as he makes the throw
a dazzling play
on the second base side of the bag
diving in the hole and then scrambling
to his feet and while falling down
through on target to get freddy freeman
at first base still the reds nine braves
won kyle farmer the only red who was yet
to reach today he's never had a chance
as robust as this year with the reds
[Applause]
just inside the pole
makes it double-digit runs for the reds
he goes deep in his hometown
i love the hold pose after he hits his
ball he kind of checks it out wondering
if it's going to be fair or foul and
then wondering if it's going to be
far enough a paint scraper that's got to
be a cool moment for kyle farmer you
know that feels good back to the top of
the order to ozzy alves even though the
braves are down 11-1 i'm sure ozzy's
still riding high from last night's
heroics
as ozzie tomahawks that ball to deep
right center field that's headed for the
atlanta bullpen and it's in the atlanta
bullpen
homer's in back-to-back games for ozzy
albees and he joins the 20 club that's
his 20th
and the braves get a two-out solo home
run
if you're going to throw that pitch to
ozzie with his swing path that ball is
going to end up a lot of times in the
bullpen or chop house and he did it
again and we go to the night reds 11
braves two
tyler stevenson first pitch peterson
decided to stay in
and he won't get to that one tyler
stevenson a home run in his hometown
with his whole family on hand
how darn cool is that well you talk
about giving them what they came for how
about that oh congratulations to tyler
to his whole family braves trying to
keep this game alive runner at first
goes that ball in the dirt that got away
that's going to score a run jack
peterson will gallop home that'll make
it a 12-3 game
back door strike three and back to that
case from amir garrett the reds avoid
the sweep and get some redemption as
they rock atlanta 12 to 3.
[Music]